hi i'm priyanka vergaria a developer
advocate for google cloud and in this
video i'll show you how to create an
ecommerce website with google cloud
there are multiple ways to create a
retail website in this video i'll walk
you through one such approach called
headless commerce
headless commerce is where you decouple
the front end your mobile app your cms
from your backend or your commerce layer
this approach provides flexibility to
your marketing teams to quickly alter
front-end elements to run campaigns and
promotions and create the most advanced
customer experience for any front-end
device by the end of this video you will
understand the basics of how to build a
headless commerce application you will
see a front-end experience deployed on
cloud run in google cloud and integrated
with commerce back-end from google cloud
marketplace offering partner commerce
tools all right let's get started
first things first if you logged into
the console for the first time create a
project
a project is required to use google
cloud and forms the basis of creating
enabling and using all the google cloud
services
i'm going to be using this one for our
demo today
on the left navigation select billing
and link your billing account
go to billing anytime for an accurate
up-to-date picture of your cloud
spending
you can view all products and learn more
about them read documentation work on a
quick start and even navigate to
individual products
if you prefer to use the command line
interface from the top right corner you
can activate cloud shell which is an
online terminal preloaded with utilities
such as the gcloud command line tool
qctl and more
now that you know how to navigate
through the console let's look into the
headless commerce project here you have
the cloudrun instance for our ecommerce
front end it is built on wui storefront
and deployed in a serverless container
if you are wondering why we are using
cloudrun here it's because it allows you
to deploy serverless containers you
don't need to worry about scaling up or
down as traffic patterns change
once the service is deployed you can see
it in the cloud run service details page
and here is what the service looks like
in order for this to work we need to
plug into a backend so let's talk about
the backend now
we could just create a back-end
ourselves but that would require us to
create all the microservices for
products orders cards etc and we have an
example for that here
creating your own vacuum can be a lot of
work and can be time-consuming the time
which your development team can spend
elsewhere
which is why in this solution we are
using a headless approach a faster way
to connect with pre-built back-end apis
the benefit of this approach is that you
can update the front-end without having
to touch the back-end
this separation also makes it easier to
update the front-end while maintaining
compliance with security and other
standards for the backend it also helps
with maintaining consistent performance
for the end-to-end client experience as
you apply updates to your front-end
alright so how do we actually do this
we have google cloud marketplace which
offers quick deploy software solutions
the partners such as commerce tools on
marketplace allows you to create this
integration right inside the console
after setting up a trial account on
commerce tools and logging in i created
an api client to connect the front-end
with the commerce tools back-end
which offers
products
categories
customers
orders and other services
after both the front end and back end
are set up we can deploy the website
and see that it works
and as we saw at the beginning of this
tutorial the storefront on cloud run can
be accessed at the deployed url
you can also see the logs and metrics in
the cloudrun deployed service with
request count
latency billable instance time and other
utilization metrics
you just learned how to build a headless
commerce application with front-end
experience deployed on cloud-run and
back-end apis on commerce tools in
google cloud marketplace thanks for
watching i encourage you to sign up for
a free trial and follow this tutorial
yourself